they did a study of California
entrepreneurs and I asked them how do
you make your decisions these are people
who built the business from nothing to
hundreds of millions or billions of
dollars and they more or less said the
same strategy I'm a voracious gatherer
of information I want to see the numbers
but if it doesn't feel right I won't go
ahead with the deal they're tuning into
the gut feelings I know someone I grew
up in a farm region of California the
Central Valley and my high school had a
rival High School in the next town and I
met him someone who went to that other
high school he almost he was not a good
student he almost failed he didn't
graduate came close to not graduating
high school he went to a two-year
college at community college that we
call them found his way into film which
he loved and got into a film school in
film school his student project caught
the eye of a director who asked him to
become an assistant and he did so well
at that that the director arranged for
him to direct his own film someone
else's script he did so well at that
they let him direct a script that he had
written and that film did surprisingly
well so the studio that financed that
film said if you want to do another one
we will back you and he however hated
the way the studio edited the film he
felt he was a creative artist and they
had butchered his art he said I'm gonna
do the film on my own I'm gonna finance
it myself
this was everyone in the film business
that he knew said this is a huge mistake
you shouldn't do this but he went ahead
then he ran out of money had to go to 11
banks before he could get a loan he
finished managed to finish the film you
may have seen the film it's called Star
Wars so George Lucas made a decision on
the basis of his gut it didn't feel
right to let the studio mangle his next
gnome he it was his integrity and this
inner sense
is ethical it's an ethical rudder you
know it answers the question is what I'm
about to do in keeping with my sense of
meaning values purpose and ethics that's
not a question that we answer first in
words we answer first and what feels
right and doesn't feel right then we put
it into words and every leader today
needs a strong ethical rudder